ready ready
[Applause]
in Jamaica sprinting is part of the
national identity the medals on the
world stage a punctuation of true
Independence
for these young men their kings and
queens are on the track the monarchy on
the other hand faces an uncertain future
here of course you look forward to
what's coming new and I look forward to
seeing what King Charles will do
differently than his mother did do you
think that Jamaica should hold a
referendum on becoming a republic I
think there should I think that there's
a trend right now with the bigger
Caribbean countries Barbados and
Trinidad both becoming republics Jamaica
is ready for republicism
a visit by the then Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge to Jamaica earlier this year
was marked by calls for an apology for
slavery and polls suggest over half of
Jamaicans want to break away from the
monarchy
and the country's prime minister is
under pressure to put the choice to the
people afternoon prime minister will you
be holding a referendum on Jamaica
becoming a republic sir
the ties to the monarchy particularly in
the capital Kingston Run Deep and for an
older generation which cherishes
tradition the death of the queen marks
the sad end of an era
I am the first one crying in Jamaica
because he's just a human being like
everybody and I love her so much in the
the best of Jamaica was back in the 60s
connection with England that was the
best of Jamaica
others believe that
what's next
um we know what is King Charles III
going to bring to the table historian
Alexis is an expert in the country's
Colonial past
do people here feel like there's been a
meaningful apology for slavery oh
definitely not
um there there's never been to us an
apology yeah you know they're sort of
like
kind of apologies and roundabout
apologies
but not a real sincere apology for the
atrocities of our former enslaved
African ancestors does that need to come
from the royal family before it needs to
come from the royal family and the
British government
um both hopefully at the same time
complex challenges in the Commonwealth
lie ahead for the new king this Jamaica
is evolving and its views are too an
island which may well choose to cut
itself adrift from old institutions
Martha kalmers Sky News Kingston Jamaica